So, hello. This past OKR, the Academy team, that's me and Adam, have been working on some
new HTTP2 labs based on James's new research on the topic. So the Web Security Academy
is basically a free online resource that you can use to learn about vulnerabilities that you can find in websites.
So you can bring up a small little sandbox website, which is vulnerable to one little thing, which you can learn to exploit
and learn how these vulnerabilities come about. So it's a really useful tool.
And basically, we've created six new labs which are going to be added soon to be released to the Academy,
which are eagerly awaited in anticipation of James's Black Hat talk three months ago.
So to get an understanding of this, I'm going to first off talk about what HTTP is in general.
So when you make a request to a website, your browser sends a request over HTTP to the web server and it sends you a response.
So if you're looking at HTTP 1, I'm going to show you a quick example.
So let's imagine this is you in a bar.
You go up to the bar keeper and you send a request. So you want the website up there.
They process the request and then sends it back to you. That's fine. It works well.
So this bar, they've heard about HTTP 2. It's meant to be faster than HTTP 1, the predecessor.
So they want to implement it. The only problem is they don't really want to go and teach their bar keeps how to understand this new protocol.
So they go and hire a waiter or they have a front end which can understand this new protocol.
They can understand it and then translate it to HTTP 1 so the bartender can understand what's going on.
So now you can send an HTTP 2 request to the waiter.
The waiter will translate this to HTTP 1.
The bar keep will process your order, give that to the waiter and then the waiter forwards it back to you.
So it basically looks like the website supports HTTP 2.
The problem happens though when there's an opportunity for misunderstanding between the front end and the back end.
So let's say you notice that when translating from HTTP 2 to HTTP 1 something can go wrong.
So you decide to send a really messy request to the waiter.
Like you want lots of sides, lots of substitutions.
The waiter, he takes that request and tries to tell the bartender what you want.
The bartender, he gets a little bit confused by this request.
So he sees the first thing there, beer, gives that to the waiter and the waiter's like,
alright sure, and then gives that back to you.
So then this other patron of the bar comes along and makes a request to the waiter.
The waiter forwards that on to the bartender.
The bartender, he's a bit muddled at the moment.
So he just sees what's in front of them from your last request because he's still trying to deal with that.
So he just hands that to the waiter and the waiter's like, alright sure, and gives that to Elon.
Elon asked for beer unfortunately, so he's not very happy with what he got back.
So this is basically how HTTP vulnerabilities can come along.
You can essentially smuggle a request and confuse the backend in a way that they'll serve the wrong request to the wrong responses to the wrong people essentially.
So the Academy Labs originally, well, they only supported HTTP 1 previously.
HTTP 2, I'm not going to go into the details, but it's a very complicated,
complicated protocol to implement or support rather.
So in order to support it, we looked at some third party support like Apache and Netty that we could use instead of implementing it ourselves.
The only problem with that is they're meant to be secure by default, meant to be, and they're not easily configurable in a way that we could emulate the vulnerabilities that we wanted to.
Thankfully, the pro team were kind enough to use burps HTTP 2 stack to create a little library for us that we could use to support the protocol.
And after we got that, and a lot of back and forth, trying to get the labs working, we've finally got the six labs ready, and they should be released relatively soon.
So to give you a little taste, I'm going to play a clip of me solving one for labs.
In this website, there's an admin of the site that goes there, that tries to log in every so often, and we can confuse the website in a way that will send the response to their login to us.
So we can steal their login and then delete one of the users of the site.
This is what hacking really looks like.
!